[Applause]
[Music]
ethiopia and visualpolitik go
way back it's a country of miracles
since 2018 we've been telling you how
its new president abby ahmed is turning
the country into a fully fledged
democracy with a growing economy he
already has a nobel peace prize under
his belt and here on visualpolitik we
have named him politician of the year
twice
hey get over it joe biden however all
this enthusiasm for abby ahmed
evaporates when we come across news
headlines like this
[Music]
ezioba's prime minister trades his nobel
peace prize for civil war bloomberg
boom that's some blow right but friends
wait a minute and haters take a second
before heading to the comments because i
owe you an explanation and i always pay
back my debts you will soon see that
things are much more complicated than
they seem
why why has this ethiopian miracle ended
up in armed conflict
has abi ahmed fooled everyone and become
the new warlord of africa today we are
going to answer these questions but
first let's take a little look back at
some history
[Music]
one country 80 ethnicities ethiopia and
liberia
the only african countries that have
never been colonized
although it is true that for a while
ethiopia was occupied by mussolini's
italy but believe me in ethiopia they
haven't needed the wicked european
imperialists to create problems among
its more than 100 million inhabitants up
to 80 different ethnic groups can be
distinguished and these ethnic groups
get along with each other because how
can i say it
let's say that no one has celebrated
social distancing measured imposed by
covid more than ethiopians
for decades the only thing that has held
ethiopians together
is the strength of the power they were
subjected to our history begins in 1991
at that time ethiopia went from being a
communist dictatorship to becoming
another communist dictatorship
and you will say what a change well the
truth is that actually
yes it was a radical change
[Music]
from 1974 to 1991 ethiopia was dominated
by the durge a savage military junta the
durge were responsible for the famous
famines in ethiopia in the 1980s
do you remember michael jackson's we are
the world
well that song was composed to raise
funds to help this country in those
years
more than one million ethiopians died of
hunger because of the collectivization
of land imposed by the durge in 1991
after a long and bloody war the durge
were driven from power and so a new
ethiopia was born an ethiopia that would
follow a model similar to that of
chinese communism in fact relations
between china and ethiopia have always
been very good but that's another story
for another video the truth is that
among all those guerrilla groups two
stood out on the one hand there was the
eritrean gorilla group which had
achieved independence for its own
country
on the other hand there was the tplf the
tigray people's liberation
front the tigray are one of ethiopia's
80 ethnic groups they
are in the north of the country very
close to eritrea and represents six
percent of the entire population
however as they were the ones who
defeated the durge they became the
masters of the new ethiopia in fact
their leader
mele zanawi ruled the entire country for
17 years
and you're probably thinking but what
difference does it make which ethnic
group this man belongs to it does matter
it matters a lot in ethiopia ethnicity
means everything in fact the ethiopian
parliament is not divided into parties
but into ethnicities
what's more the whole country is divided
into nine regions
these regions are called kililock in the
plural or kilil in the singular
well the borders of these killilock are
drawn on the basis of ethnic criteria
for example tigray is one of these
killilock one of these regions where 96
percent of the population belongs to the
tigray ethnic group for years
all the power in ethiopia has been
shared between the tigray who didn't
come out of the war empty-handed the
oromos and the amharis which are the
majority ethnic groups and here is where
the problem comes
because the current ethiopian prime
minister belongs to the oromo ethnic
group
in fact he became prime minister because
of the amhara gave him their support
and that means that the tigray lost all
their influence in the rest of the
country so what happened next well let's
take a look at that right now
[Music]
the last roar of the tigre abbey ahmed
came to power in april 2018
yet two years before the next federal
elections which were to be held in
mid-2020 but
two years were enough to turn the
country around from the outset he signed
a peace treatment with eritrea with whom
ethiopia had been at war for almost 30
years but the most
important thing is that he removed all
the laws that censored the media and
announced
free elections
[Music]
in other words unlike the previous
elections these were not going to be a
mere formality that ended up with the
tribal leaders choosing the prime
minister however democratizing a country
like ethiopia is no bed of roses in
other visualpolitik videos we have
already told you about the problems it
has had with various other ethnic groups
but now the problem comes down to this
[Music]
ethiopia prime minister abi ahmed
dismisses army chief of staff
and intelligence director in a major
military shake-up protests in tigre
oh pride ethiopia arrests government
officials over corruption the africa
report
former ethiopian minister jailed for
corruption a.a
as you can see abby ahmed's strategy is
to eliminate the power quota that the
tigrays have had since the 1990s and as
you can imagine
this news didn't sit well in the tigray
region after 30 years of dominating
ethiopia it is not easy to accept that
you have lost power but the last roar
came at the end of 2020. the current
leader of the tigray region de brzezion
gabriel michael
is someone who has challenged abby ahmed
to become the prime minister of ethiopia
in 2020 he was planning to run again in
the elections the idea was that these
elections would not be a mere formality
they had to be free
in a country like ethiopia that means
having a census and taking a census in a
poor country of 100 million people
is not exactly easy as if all this
weren't enough the coronavirus pandemic
has only complicated matters further
conclusion abby ahmed proposed delaying
the elections until 2021
and then this happened
[Music]
ethiopian prime minister's term extended
as election delayed for virus
ap news the tigrays insisted that abby
ahmed's legitimacy ended in 2020. so
they challenged the federal power in
addis abada and announced that they
would hold their own
elections in tigray kilil in september
and i say
elections because deb retzey and gabriel
michael got 98.2 percent of the votes
abby ahmed did not stand still
either because he decided to reduce the
federal funds dedicated to the tigray
region as a means of pressure against
the tplf but the real challenge came in
october
news tigray region says it will defy
federal laws
enacted as of october 5th at its
standard keep in mind that the tigray
region is one with the most prepared
army in fact
the northern command of the ethiopian
army is based there and many have
speculated that these soldiers might
change sides in the event of a war
against the federal government
but the point of no return took place on
the 4th of november when tplf forces
attacked the bases of the federal army's
northern command the tplf assures that
this attack never took place and then it
was just an excuse
used by abby ahmed to invade tigray so
who is in the right well
what can i say apart from who finds the
first shot there are two things that
leave the tplf
looking very bad the first is that the
tigres have bombed eritrea with the aim
of internationalizing the conflict and
provoking
other actors such as the african union
to intervene
after three decades representing
ethiopia abroad the tigrays still have
friends on the international stage
do you want an example have you heard of
a certain tedros adhannam gabriel jesus
that's right he's none other than the
current director of the world
health organization and is a member of
the tplf but there is a second reason to
condemn
what the tigres have done and that is
ethnic cleansing
to grand youth group accused of massacre
in ethiopia bbc
more than 600 civilians mostly amhara
were found dead
in my kendra when federal troops entered
this small town we are talking about an
area in the killing of tigray that the
amhara claim has their own it was
amnesty international who indicated the
perpetrators were a group of young to
great people
on 28th of november abbey ahmed
proclaimed victory in the war against
the tplf
after the seizure of the capital of
tigray
the rebel forces have taken refuge in
the mountains and assure that they will
continue to confront abiamid however it
seems more like bravado on the part of
the tigray because they are no longer
those young people who overthrew the
dirge but a group of sexeogenarians
who refused to recognize that they lost
power long ago even so abby ahmed has
important challenges ahead of him
[Music]
the moment of truth it is true
ethiopia's internal crisis has brought
out its ruler's worst side
internet and telephone lines have been
cut off again in the oromia and tigre
areas so that it is not known for sure
what is going on there in addition
there are testimonies that claim that
the government forces have surpassed
themselves in the use of force the human
rights violations are terrible but at
least for the first time
an ethiopian ruler has been capable of
self-criticism look at the explanation
he gave in a letter to the economist
given the institutions we have inherited
we realize that law enforcement
activities entail a risk of human rights
violations and abuse
the mindset and tactics of the past are
not so easy to unlearn
security and judicial reforms take time
abi ahmed
prime minister of ethiopia it is true
that political transitions are
complicated and require time but we must
be clear abby ahmed's moment of truth
has come it is time for him to show that
his promises were sincere because so far
he has shown his most authoritarian side
he has barely even tried to negotiate
with the opposition for three weeks the
tplf forces have held out against the
advance of the federal army so now this
threat has been neutralized abi ahmed
must return to his initial road map
and that means returning to tigre as
normal something that does not seem to
be happening at the moment since the
galilee of tigray has been excluded from
participating in the next elections the
national election board has claimed that
there is now an interim government there
and that it has quite a bit of work
ahead of it before elections can be held
however this is not the worst problem it
has to deal with
ethnic profiling of tigrans heightens
tensions in ethiopia the new
humanitarian since the crisis broke out
there have been multiple reports of
ethnic discrimination against the
tigrays throughout the rest of the
country it is claimed that tigray
officials have been ordered not to go to
work are members of the ethiopian
security
forces belonging to this ethnic group
have been disarmed nothing justifies
this revanchism all the ethnic purging
against these citizens with the defeat
of the tplf abby ahmed has to keep his
promises and i'm sure there's more than
one person
thinking in the end this abbey ahmed
doesn't seem much better than the tigray
but we must remember that the tigray
have enjoyed enormous levels of power
for decades and they are not making
things easy for the current president
in fact in regards to the other ethnic
groups abbey ahmed is fulfilling his
promises for example do you remember
what i told you about the right to
self-determination of people's being a
dead letter well yes it was for decades
but the government of abi ahmed has
already allowed this right
to self-determination to be successfully
practiced
referendum over 98 vote yes for
ethiopia's 10th regional state
africa news seven months after the
referendum it was already a reality
ethiopia became 10 kililock when the
sadama people constituted their own kill
little and declared their autonomy and
take note because this may not be the
last referendum there are already 10
ethnic groups that have asked for their
own
autonomy referendums and i know what
many of you will be thinking
since when is it good news for a country
to be divided along racial lines
well the truth is that democratizing a
country like ethiopia is not easy and
for the moment this seems to be the most
realistic solution
but the question is now over to you do
you think that these referendums are a
good solution to alleviate ethnic
tensions
do you think that abby ahmed is right
with this hardline approach against the
tigres or do you think that he will show
up later in the year on visualpolitik as
one of the politicians who disappointed
us the most in 2021 leave your answers
down in the comments below so i really
hope you enjoyed this video please hit
like if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos
and as always i'll see you next time and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider media.com
podcast see you there